super mario brothers 35th anniversary  themed items are coming to the animal  crossing new horizons game  familiar items like the super mushroom  and the question block can be ordered in  game as furniture items  so place them however and wherever you'd  like  [Music]  you can also place two warp pipes  then use them to travel between  locations on your island  hey why not try recreating the mushroom  kingdom  [Music]  a free update for the game launches  february 25th  after downloading it super mario  brothers items will be available via  nook shopping starting march 1st  keep an eye on the official animal  crossing twitter account for the latest  information  we hope you continue enjoying life on  your island  how was that these items  will be released as part of the super  mario brothers 35th anniversary events  please wait a bit longer for their  release